bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e
questo nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo sullo speciale 75mila
iscritti rega e sta assurdo è che siamo
arrivati ad un numero così grande di
iscritti ragazzi non me lo sarei
veramente mai aspettato l'unico sempre
lo so che le avete le palle piene mista
frase ma vi giuro che ogni volta c'è
un'emozione incredibile grazie mille per
questo traguardo incredibile mi scuso se
non ho fatto speciali ultimamente da
dopo i 50 mila euro detto non ne facevo
più
ogni 5000 iscritti però siamo passati
dal farne troppi al farne troppo pochi
mi sembra un'esagerazione essere
arrivati fino a questo punto quindi
aumenterò un pochettino ritmo dei e dei
video speciali da adesso in avanti state
tranquilli quindi da capire questi 65
mila iscritti che cosa vai avrei potuto
fare avrei potuto far spiaccicare al
muro mio amico e mi onora e vai
oppure avrei potuto filmare mio padre
mentre gioca just dance
chiamarla così
ma questo lo vedrete nei prossimi
speciali anzi mi vedrete ballare just
dance molto presto non nei prossimi
speciali ma nei prossimi video mah vabbè
tanto lo avete già letto da titolo
quindi sapete di che tratta questo video
e tenete conto che se una ragazza
commenta un video non vi aspettate che
lo commenti come lo commento io perché
io sono uno youtuber quindi le basi per
commentare io le conosco diciamo che
prende una persona e parla fargli fare
un video su youtube non è più o meno la
stessa cosa un tentativo ci si può
provare non vi aspettate
ribadisco un commento come come sono
commenta ceo perché a questo punto non
sarebbe stato uno speciale non vi do
normale
detto questo spero che comunque video vi
possa divertire li possa piacere è
quindi direi che possiamo cominciare da
wired.it nuovi chip corri
aspetta aspetta si no
donna ferma
lascia parlare club lascia parlare i
nerd vsd ti muovi si va avanti
brava anche il tasto esterna donna
all'altra stesso dietro perché perfetto
tasso a chigi dice non voglio meno mi
dire bravo e poi il mouse questo
aggeggio qui piccolo dei premi serve a
girare tra visuale quindi se tu con la
brava brava brava
traviss che raccoglie e ferma donna
ferma troppe cose allora è devi
prenderle robe immagine si sa più nulla
è perfetto fight matera beh ragazzi è
vostro non mi lasciare qui maledetto a
pagine dietro suggerimenti da fondo
campo
allora dove la vedi l'albero dovrebbe
esserci l'ho fatto io sto già allora
quel manichino bellissimo che ti appare
per apparire una volta inizia a prendere
parte pero falliscono
ecco la cosa la prendo e 30
bravissima e una comincia a sentire
ecco c'era una persona che si è sempre
c'è qualcosa di diverso mi piace sono io
ah sì destra 4 che brown si ti lascio
nelle maglie da te ti lascia nelle mani
di quel bravo ragazzo giovane star
switch prendete lui
ci sono ragazzi che portano in giro la
propria ragazza nei parchi no
facciamola giocare al menti io ho un
concetto di morte contro un precario
quindi io io rimorchio inviato non cosa
correvo con questo mi sta andando a caso
ecco dai posti adesso riusciamo ancora
non si è visto le vicine ma perché sono
io entra nelle case dove o cosa
sbagliata dove dove dove sono bloccata
merda
[Musica]
no no no no non è vero
no
certo sempre attivo lo sapete automatico
non voglio di circa non possono
viaggiare tranquilli che mario
[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie al sì dai pupazzetti
come faccio a salire come faccio a
salita sopra grazie vice all
perché non mi sa perché non mi vado a
sopra
[Musica]
nessuno all'inizio che tu ma io insegno
a bastava aspettare
vai vai vai meglio cosa devo sfogare non
sono morta da vi aggiorno orami qui
[Musica]
vai con calma dove calma ce la facciamo
no io devo riuscirci se non ci restava
prometteva bene come faccio ora che è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi ci ha provato io mi sento libero di
chi sto parlando
[Musica]
chi è stato meno bravo di te
allora ragazzi questa cosa un po strana
questi trucchi non sono per me